be precise
if you want people to listen to you if
you want to get media you want to get
partners you want to get customers on
board with your company then they have
to quickly understand what it is that
your business does and how it helps them
and it comes from being precise in your
messaging
this week i've had a lot of
entrepreneurs for some reason that have
come to me and have not been precise
in what they're asking for
this morning i met with an entrepreneur
and i love the direction of his company
i love what he stands for but as he's
telling me his story
i'm starting to get bored
he's rambling on about all sorts of
things that are not relevant or
interesting
and i start to daydream
i start to think about other projects
i'm working on other people that i'm
going to be meeting and i'm fighting i'm
fighting to stay with him and to listen
i'm really trying but he's losing me
constantly and and i had to stop him
halfway through and say
i'm starting to zone out
like you need to really get to the point
and be precise with what it is you're
doing and how i can help you here today
like i am here for an hour this coffer
meeting to help you
tell me what i can do to help you but i
was struggling to find that answer
i get it happen to me a lot when people
write in to me as well i had two emails
this week from entrepreneurs who just
wrote like a novel in their emails and
i'm scrolling and scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
just non-stop it seems
and there's no way i have the time to
read all of that and to give some advice
if you are trying to reach out to
successful people you'll find that they
really value their time that's what
makes them successful and the more
successful they are the more they're
going to value their time and the less
time they're going to have to waste on
something that is not relevant
interesting or helpful to them so you
have to quickly get to the point and be
precise now when somebody writes me
those crazy long emails i'll usually
write back and i'll say
love to help you please rewrite this and
take 80 of it out and it forces them to
be precise
and cut down their language into
something that i can digest more easily
and for those who do
i'll write back i'll try to help them as
much as i can
and for those who don't if they don't
invest the time in themselves to create
copy
that is relevant and powerful then why
should i waste my time trying to help
you
if you have this challenge if you are
writing crazy long emails to people and
you can't seem to get your point across
quickly
all the business advice it's going to be
really hard to get out of people like
for these people who write into me
i can't really even help you until i
understand what it is that you do so
your biggest business problem
is
condensing your thoughts into something
that people can understand
and i know it's it can be a huge ask
especially if you're first getting
started in a business i remember when i
had my first presentations i remember
one in particular was in dubai and i was
so nervous i got up on stage and there's
hundreds of people in the audience it's
my first real presentation
and i wanted to cram so much in there
that i started talking really quickly
and and
sharing everything that i could on the
topic i felt like i'd add ad
and just share everything not miss any
detail
and as a result i lost most of the
people and they came to me and said we
love your energy but we have no idea
what you were talking about
and this happens to all of us i know
it's very nerve-wracking
but it's so important that you practice
this
it's so important you have a good
elevator pitch to explain what it is
your business is all about and it's so
important when you're reaching out to
people for help
that they quickly and easily understand
what you do so then they can give you
some good advice to actually help you
so your homework for today
is be precise create a quick elevator
pitch that anybody can understand what
it is that you do
practice it talk to yourself in the
mirror prepare
and the next time you go out and talk to
somebody
let that shine through and only say the
words you need to to get your point
across
believe
for those of you watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it always makes me want to do more
videos for you and i want to hear you
have to think please leave a comment
below let me know your thoughts i'd love
to do a video response for you thank you
so much and i'll see you soon